اتمنى اتمنى الان لمسؤولين في وزاره
التعليم ان يجعلونا الذكاء العاطفي منهجا
والله
نسب البطاله ونسب الطلاق والسجون ستخف
والعلاقات الجسم ايش معنى دكتور ساشرح لك
الان الان
ساحكي لك مشهدا وقل لي اذا كان واجهك في
حياتك اولا ما سبق نقابلت انسان معدلاته
عاليه وتخصصه دقيق
وما شاء الله تبارك الله يملك القدره
عقليه عاليه لكنه بالمصطلح هذه بذر
وغثيث وصعب وممل ولا احد يقدر يتعايش معه
هذا عنده الايكي واللي يسمى حاصل الذكاء
عالي الذكاء العقلي قدرات العقليه عاليه
لكن اجتماعيه
ان يكون زوجا جيدا ولا موظفا جيدا ولا
صديقا صحيحا ما تمكنه جزء كبير من من
هؤلاء في في في اماكن محدوده
المعول عليها الان بحسب بعض الدراسات 75
الى 80% من ما انت عليه الان من راح
وسعاده ونجاح واو واو حتى في كل مناحي
الحياه يعتمد على ذكائك العاطفي الذكاء
العاطفي 20 15
بين الذكاء العاطفي الذكيا عاطفيا لو ان
تكون عاطفيا او رومانسيه او رومانسيه
حب
بليه غلط
مشاعرك وادارتها معناها مختلف ترى تماما
عن مساله الانسان العاطفي العاطفيه ولا
الدفاع في العاطفيه كلها غلط لكن ذكاء
العاطف على فهم مشاعرك وادارتها وفهم
مشاعر الاخرين وايضا التعامل معها يعني
انا اقول شوف من من اعطيك شيء من مكونات
الذره الوعي بالذات
البشر في جملتهم يعني عندهم قدره على ان
يعرفوا تفاصيل الاخرين لكنه لو عن نفسه
سالت عن نفسه ما يعرف نفسه ما يعرف نفس
الوعي بذات انت تعرف نفسك ولا لا يا اخي
بعض الناس يمارس اخطاء بشكل يومي فيها
ايذاء وفيها جرح وفيها اعتداء وفيها اشياء
في ضد مصلحتي لكن غير واعي فيها يقول
كلمات احيانا احيانا لا يقول لكنه غير
واعي فيها واسهر انواع الوعي ليس الوعي
الوعي بالسلوك ممكن
الوعي بالمشاعر الى اخطر انواع الوحي
الوحي بالافكار
احنا في بعض الناس عنده افكار تشاميه
احيانا عنده افكار يعني
متمسك بالماضي احيانا عنده افكار تجاه
المستقبل تشاؤميه وكارثيه لذلك الوعي
بالذات قيمه عاليه ايضا وعيك بمشاعرك انت
كيف ستسيطر على مشاعر وانت لا تعرفها
تسميه المشاعر مهمه ان تسمي مشاعرك وان
تعرف اثرها على الاخرين لماذا قال الحبيب
اللهم صل وسلم عليه لا يقضي القاضي حين
يقضي وهو غضبان لان الغضبان في حاله معينه
لا يستطيع لا يعني لا يستطيع معها ان
يوفقها الى الحكم لذلك هذا والحديث عن
الذكاء العاطفي حديث ذو سجون وقد سالتني
عن عظيم يعطيك حاجه مهمه الذكاء العاطفي
ليس فضل معرفه ولا ترى فكري بل هو غروره
من ضرورات الحياه همم دكتور همم الملل
ايضا يمكن من الاشياء اللي يمر فيها
الانسان وخاصه كثير همم
حياته اليوميه كانت ممكن الانسان يواجه
هذا لازم
ههه هذا قضيه مهمه ترى مو لازم كل لحظه
وله هو بضدها تتميز الاشياء يا اخي يا اخي
من الاشياء المهمه في علم النفس الايجابي
ما يسمى بين تقبل بعض الامور ومنها الملل
الملل هي حياتك اليوم والله فيها شيء من
الفرحه وفيها شيء من البهجه بكره اقل شوي
بعده اقل شوي تقبلوا وجود الملل وخلينا
يعطيك حاجه على الملل ما الذي يسبب الملل
سبحان الله النفس التي لا تريد يوميا
تجديد اعطيك حاجه مهمه يعطيك يعني يوم من
الايام احدهم يقول لك اولادي ما شاء الله
تعالى وبركاته يعني كثير السفر
فقل حسين احساسنا وهذا خطا الاعتماد وفي
حياتك على امر ما تتمحور عليه سعادتك خطا
من الاشياء الجميله التي انا انا شخصيا
امارسها لكي اقطع احيانا بعض حالات او
اخفف منها لا انتظر شيء جديد بل انني
استثمر ما لدي في بعض الاشياء كثيره في
حياتنا الان لم تستثمر بشكل جيد ايضا من
الاشياء تقطع الحاله النفسيه وحاله الملل
وتعطيك شويه روح في حياتك يا اخي نعمه
نعمه الامتنان وهي من النعم والمهارات انا
اقول شبه المفقوده ودائما بعض الناس اذا
سالناها خالد قال لنا كيف حالك ايش امور
قال والله الامور على حالها وانا يعني
خرجتو بامر بالنسبه لي في غايه الاهميه
الحمد لله كثير الاشياء المتغيرت ارتبكت
الحياه